hello nice to see you again sorry it's
been a little while I am currently
hiking in Algonquin Park in Ontario
Canada this particular hike is called
whose Rock Trail it's pretty lovely one
it's very pretty
lots of history around here lots of mud
and mosquitoes just what you'd expect
from the Canadian wilderness however
please do not be fooled into thinking
this video is more exciting that
actually is I'm just here to tell you
what I'm gonna do at VidCon this year
but if you can make it through then the
promise you'll get a nice view of Canada
at the end so as your incentive so the
first thing is my new short film which
I'm hoping will be finished in time to
screen at VidCon and we're already at
the view so that's good this isn't the
main view okay so I can just not show it
to them good it looks like a beautiful
painting and you're missing out sorry so
yeah if you would like to see my new
short film strangers in a bed in its
hopefully finished form
I think we'll be screening that on
Saturday we are actually here at the
view now that way you get you go enjoy
it I'll update them and then I'll come
join you Emily and I have also organized
our own panel this year called
intermix basic concept is that we wanted
to try and bring together filmmakers
from a more traditional background who
are releasing their films online and
filmmakers like myself who started doing
stuff online and now are getting into
filmmaking so that's gonna be a
screening of lots of short films online
and then I'm gonna bring out some of the
filmmakers have a chat with them so
hopefully that will be entertaining for
you as well if you'd like to come along
to that that is also on the Saturday
again not sure what time and then as per
normal I'm also gonna try and meet as
many people who want to meet me as I
possibly can so on Thursday and Friday
I'm doing a mix of taking pictures with
people and signing things for people
can't remember which ones on which day
again just very very good at this whole
update thing I'm on a couple of panels
as well that I haven't organized which
also film a key related to can't
remember what those are called at all so
that's useful tell you what I'll do is I
write a blog post
we've correct information in it so you
can look at that I'll put it in the
description and that's it my arm hurts
now I want to go look at a view so
hopefully I will see it VidCon okay
here's the view good lord that's pretty
holy
holy hell holy mackerel
do you like it yeah let's have lunch the
end you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like who
okay it's been try and film this bit Oh
God
[Music]